hey welcome to the amber wrapping show
the only late night show that pays its
staff in candy
we're filming in studio 8g at
rockefeller center where seth meyers
films his show
late night with seth meyers now we don't
have a studio audience but we do have
a terry davis he's my announcer sidekick
and real life friend
say hi derek hi tarik hey tarik
what's the best thing that happened to
you this week um ask me after the
monologue
okay you guys it's been a crazy week in
america
let's find out what happened president
biden said this week that
the united states will share an
additional 20 million
coronavirus vaccines with other
countries adding quote
we want to lead the world with our
values
which is why every one of those vaccines
will come with a gun
amazon announced a new program this week
called
working well which is designed to help
improve
employees mental health while on the job
and then
they gave each employee their own
personalized urinal
oh no i'm owner working well
we can tell all working well
[Music]
um
expert whistlers the ruffins no one
likes us citing human rights abuses
house speaker nancy pelosi announced
her support this week for a boycott of
the 2022 winter olympics in beijing
which is too bad because she just
qualified
so good she's really good she's not
going to represent our country it's a
shame
we might lose after republican lawmakers
signaled opposition this week to a
bipartisan commission to investigate the
capital riots
house speaker nancy pelosi called it
quote disappointing but not surprising
disappointing but not surprising is also
what melania calls
doing it with donald trump oh
can i try disappointing but not
surprising
is what i say every time i taste an ipa
disappointing but not surprising is what
i say when a white guy busts out an
acoustic guitar
at a party oh disappointing but not
surprising is how i describe
improv shows on zoom and improv shows in
general
disappointing but not surprising is what
people are going to say about this bit
according to a new book after vice
president kamala harris
criticized president biden's record on
school busing during the first
democratic presidential primary debate
president biden whispered an expletive
laid in remark
to mayor pete butterjudge he he was like
how old are you
[Laughter]
google previewed a new tool this week
that helps people identify possible skin
conditions
using their phone cameras it's called ew
what is that
uh it's a mustache oh thank god
thank god it's a mustache it's just my
full lady mustache
according to new research neanderthals
died out because
they were less creative than humans said
neanderthals
oh yeah well you're a
less creative than a neanderthals
oh they're gone we can make fun of a mom
dumb look at you
soon and finally mr t
turned 69 this week so he's now part of
the aarp team
huh yeah to what degree all the way
yeah and that was the monologue tarik
what was the best thing that happened to
you this week that monologue
yay well hold on to your butt cause
we're just
getting started several new york city
mayoral candidates made waves recently
when they were asked
the median price of a home in brooklyn
and they vastly underestimated it
now i'm not going to tell you what they
guessed because i actually want to
conduct a little experiment of my own
wally you're a regular joe right sure i
suppose
so let me ask you what do you think is
the median price of a home in brooklyn
top of my head top of your head 12 bucks
higher 13 bucks a lot higher
17 bucks while i think big 28
bigger 38 dollars i mean huge
100 are you messing with me i am not
more 111 wally i can do this all day
112 i'm going to smack the [ __ ] out of
you
119 final answer final answer
no wrong for sake i'm talking an order
of magnitude
larger than anything you're giving me
prices are high wally they're sky
high they're out of this world man
they're in orbit right now it's a
city-wide
issue it's a global issue okay do you
understand me do you understand what i'm
telling you about property values
i understand good now
what do you think is the average price
of a home in brooklyn
nine hundred thousand dollars that is
correct
wally congratulations you are now the
mayor of new york city
yay and i predict six more weeks of
covid
ah no sorry well wally becoming the
mayor of new york might seem like the
craziest news of the week but it's not
republican congresswoman marjorie
taylor-green came under fire this week
after a video surfaced of her verbally
harassing representative
alexandria ocasio-cortez's staff back in
2019
before green was in congress accompanied
by a few friends
green yelled at ocasio-cortez's staff
through the mail slot in her office door
and dared the congresswoman to come out
and face her
see for yourself alexandria
ocasio-cortez i'm an american citizen
i pay your salary through the taxes that
you collect from me through the irs you
need to stop being a baby and stop
locking your door and come out and face
the american citizens that you serve
if you want to be a big girl you need to
get rid of your diaper
and come out and be able to talk to the
american citizens instead of just having
to use a flap guess what
you can't stand there forever
can you come out and play
wow that is truly terrifying
hey amber what is that
hey amber ruffin i uh i think it's
coming from the mail slot
amber mildred roofing come on out here
oh my god it's marjorie taylor grain
marjorie i am not coming out there
why not because i'm pretty sure you're
going to try to murder me
i am a peacock subscriber i pay your
salary
you pay peacock's monthly subscription
fee well no i have the free version
all right well you need to stop being a
baby
and stop locking your door and come on
out and face your viewers
i don't want to why not i'm worried that
if i go out there things will get crazy
oh baby if i'm here things are already
crazy
come on come on out or let me
in i just want to talk oh yuck
i am not coming out and you sound like a
character from the purge
that's not nice why are you bullying me
you're a bully
i'm not bullying you you're shouting at
me through a mail slot on my door
it's unsettling this is pennywise
behavior
come on you have to talk to me
face to face not through this little
flap no i don't have to talk to anybody
but i'm such a fan oh yeah if you're
such a fan name one sketch on this show
when i uh um uh
mean tweets it's not even close look
marjorie it doesn't matter what you say
i'm not coming out there and you are
definitely not coming in here
if you want to be a big girl you need to
get rid of your diaper
come out from that desk and talk to me
i don't wear a diaper you wear a diaper
help
help she's bullying me help aren't you a
congress person
don't you have a job to do yes
but i i don't understand what it is
no one ever explained it to me okay well
you're a united states congressperson
your job is to represent the
constituents from your district and
to introduce and vote for legislation
that serves their best interests
so no harassing people
no that's not part of your job so
i should probably go get to work yeah
that would be great
okay hi amber
thanks for being such a snowflake
oh no marjorie taylor green everybody
we'll be right back with more of the
amber ruffin show
and i'm watching you amber roofing i
have my own youtube channel now
yay be sure to subscribe for a lot of
show clips and a lot of digital
exclusives
and a lot of this